brings back like that and maybe it was
not the same as prepared a Klitschko you
know miners are different for every fun
clutch goes like yeah like aging
obviously yes at that point yeah but I
just think that that style that Tyson
Fury style avoid that [ __ ] like measles
mmm-hmm get away yeah no there's a
reason why Joshua doesn't want to fight
while there are fury yeah because also
he is the top draw right now look he can
sell out like you know like forty fifty
thousand in his home country whereas
like Wilder like in his home state you
fight a lot in Alabama like it's like
ten thousand or something like that you
know so Josh was a bigger draw well he's
becoming I think Wilders becoming a
bigger draw nationally mm-hmm now but
it's it I think that's also one of the
things with boxing is like they're
always trying to figure out like when do
we make this fight do we make it now or
do we wait a couple of months
let me see two undefeated champions my
teacher like that doesn't really happen
that often especially in the heavyweight
division like something that's like
really special someone could [ __ ] up and
lose yeah exactly exactly as she made me
whether Pacquiao all over again where
it's like it happened but it happened
too late right exactly so stay the [ __ ]
away from Tyson Fury kids what would you
think about the McGregor mayweather
like fight it went he would did much
better than I thought he was gonna get
me to but I think that Mayweather was
probably wanting to wear him out and so
allowed him to express but he did catch
Mayweather with a very clean left he was
rapid punching the whole time that was
driving me insane just kept on just
punching the back of his head like you
yes exactly like you can't do that look
you know I'm surprised like the ref like
let him get away with murder but destroy
him I think you wanted to frustrate me
weather and get Mayweather to try to
open up yeah cuz that cuz like
Mayweather his defense is like super
tight and like no he came in there like
Mayweather fought a perfect kind of
fight he's like just I'm gonna let this
guy gas himself out and that's exactly
what he did well cousin a knockout
artist but he knocked him out you know
he definitely stopped him but Conor's
not known for his cardio yeah he's a
fast twitch guy yeah okay I think it was
when they opened up the books for that
fight it was a thousand to one from a
Gregor to win by decision listen up
I almost put a grand on that just anyway
some principle I just want I just want a
million dollars no one but I'll just sit
there and I turn to my friends like I
think I just want a million dollars do
you know how crazy that would be to win
a million dollars we're putting down
like a thousand dollar bet
[Music]
[Laughter]